Wolverine is back, and he's never looked
more like himself – but this classic suit
raises a lot of questions about what's
going on with the X-Men, and the MCU.
"What is this place?"
Ever since production began on "Deadpool 3,"
rumors surrounding the upcoming threequel have
been going ballistic online. Reports have
suggested a slew of nostalgic cameos are on
the way, including three of the original
X-Men joining Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
Pair that with the recent news of
Jennifer Garner's return as Elektra,
and "Deadpool 3" is shaping up
to be quite the multiversal story
as the Merc with a Mouth makes his big
debut in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
As if that wasn't exciting enough, Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman woke up this morning and decided
to break the internet, giving fans the first
official look at Deadpool and Wolverine in
"Deadpool 3." While both heroes are
back and looking better than ever,
all eyes are on Jackman as he finally
gets the opportunity to don Wolverine's
iconic yellow suit on the big screen, and it's
just as glorious as anyone could've imagined.
Wolverine's new look for "Deadpool 3" looks
as if he's jumped straight from the pages
of Marvel's "Astonishing X-Men" run, with
Jackman sporting the classic yellow suit
with blue accents that look just as vibrant
as they ever did in the comics. Interestingly,
this version features sleeves covering Jackman's
arms, something his comic-book counterpart never
grew accustomed to. The first look also
notably doesn't include Wolverine's iconic
cowl, but given how comic-accurate Jackman's
costume is, it probably isn't far behind him.
While Wolverine's iconic yellow suit
is more than enough to build hype
for "Deadpool 3," it could also
give fans an idea of what Marvel
Studios plans to do with the X-Men
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
While Jackman's Wolverine may be making
his MCU debut in a blue and gold suit,
that doesn't mean he's going to be the MCU's
Wolverine. Reports suggest that Deadpool 3 and
other movies in the Multiverse Saga might be more
of a swan song for the Fox X-Men characters - and
if that's the case, we'll probably be getting
a bit of a reset down the line with the MCU's
version of the character. That would likely
mean a whole new actor, and a whole new outfit,
with the eventual MCU Wolverine maybe taking
on the classic gold and brown suit instead.
First introduced in "Uncanny X-Men" #139,
Wolverine's gold and brown suit quickly
became an iconic design for the character,
wearing it throughout the '80s and early
'90s. In recent years, the costume has
had a resurgence, with Logan wearing a
modernized version for the current "X-Men"
run, priming it for a live-action debut.
As for the X-Men, Wolverine's yellow suit
in "Deadpool 3" bodes well for the entire
team. "X-Men" movies of the past decided
to forgo many of the characters' comic book
costumes. Wolverine's new look suggests
that Marvel Studios will likely stick
a little closer to the source material
for the X-Men's suits this time around.
Now that comic book movies are much more
mainstream than they were twenty years ago,
it's only natural to showcase the vibrant,
unique costumes that originally made the
X-Men staples in the comics industry. Of course,
this is all speculation, but it certainly seems
like X-Men fans are in for a treat whenever
the mutants come to the MCU in full force.
While Deadpool and Wolverine look better
than ever for their upcoming multiversal
buddy cop adventure, Hugh Jackman finally
getting his hands on Wolverine's yellow
suit pays off his long-standing
commitment to bring Logan to life.
Over 20 years ago, when "X-Men" first hit
theaters, it infamously threw out the characters'
vibrant colors, choosing to style everyone
in a uniformed black leather look instead.
"What would you prefer? Yellow spandex?"
While the scene is now iconic, the simple
answer was yes, and fans have been waiting
to see their favorite "X-Men" characters
don their classic suits ever since.
In Wolverine's case, that day never came -
until "Deadpool 3" hits theaters - but that
didn't stop the studio from teasing Jackman
in the yellow suit. "The Wolverine" filmed an
alternate ending featuring Yukio gifting Logan
a yellow and brown suit, but the scene ended
up not making the final cut. In an interview
with Screen Rant, director James Mangold said,
"I somehow feel that if somehow
we ever put Hugh [Jackman] into
one of those outfits, people would not be happy."
While that may have been the case back then,
fans seem more than excited to see Jackman
finally get his yellow suit in "Deadpool 3."